[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez mon andré at on y va comment il va
super bien ça bien il est il est
toujours été sur l'amour est dans le pré
ouais je suis sur l'amour est dans le
pré bien sûr hier soir c'était le prime
des premières séparations vous savez le
moment où les prétendantes quitte les
agriculteurs du coup il ya beaucoup
d'émotion voire peut-être un peu mois
après il ya beaucoup d'émotions et ça
s'est vérifié notamment sur les lunettes
de la nièce d'un des agriculteurs
malheureusement c'est pas si elle sort
d'une crise de larmes ou dans la maman
il ya comme un
je suis triste je n'avais pas vu des
legs s'est réalisée avec tout à sedan
mais c'est rigolo
il a regardé l'amour est dans le pré on
a donc très très lourd l'amour est dans
le pré est allé dans la rue gaba bien
sûr alors qu'est ce qu'a fait dans la
rue ouais j'aime bien pendant chez moi
le truc du coup dans la rue j'aime bien
poser des questions gênantes aux
français oui malheureusement quand c'est
trop gênant ils veulent pas répondre
alors je les ai un petit peu comment
dire ça vous adorez vous avez quand il
pose une question en fait ils ordi qui
va leur poser des questions et quand tu
arrives à caméra il en pose une autre
complètement ça tout le temps a
intéressé à l'amour est dans le pré bien
sûr on enchaîne alors je vous ai ramené
des images lui c'est son émission de
cette parcelle près de l'agro spectacle
de daniel vous savez daniel c'est cet
agriculteur super fort et super viry
lui-même qu'on s'a prétendants 220 reste
digne vient du fait des petites vannes
jusqu'à la fin sauf que quand elle est
vraiment parti le gall change d'émotion
en seconde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cannor voix
après je ne sais plus la suisse fait
tant pis moi bateau
[Musique]
voilà les voilà pourquoi je kiffe cette
émission va observer que je vous jure
j'ai un amour pour les agriculteurs
depuis cette émission se voit herman je
connaissais pas bien et voilà lui je le
kiffe eh oui j'ai envie d'aller mois
bisounours une semaine arrêtée
ouais ouais ça sert de bouche à mort et
vous vous la verriez pendant une semaine
[Rires]
voilà pourquoi vous voulez vous les
connais tous les deux avant tout
profondément marque un pas quoi c'est
beaucoup moins baho là là mais quel
petit boîtier l'agriculteur qui peut
vous accueillir à côté de chez moi
non c'est vrai sympa dans le vexin
mercialys mais bah écoutez on voit sans
voir les deux
si l'on y attirer olivin la wii va
écouter battu roddick à quoi tu voyais
allemann c'était le jour qu'on va y
aller après la laponie pour vous calmer
en irak c'est pas beau grec wallon envie
de te des veaux alors ça comme un seul
avait encore des gens qui pensent que
des hétérosexuels ou parle puisqu'il ya
encore des gens qui pensent par contre
sur tellement encore des gens qui
pensent que je vous péter la gueule vous
échange de mots comme vous le savez à
chaque réunion de famille à ce moment
gênant au ta mère sans des photos de toi
quand tu étais petit pour ta forêt le
massacre augmente alors c'est gênant
quand ça se passe devant ta conjointe
dont on a trouvé encore plus gênant
c'est la réaction du conjoint qui lui
est en roue libre
c'est anna çà et là il avait un petit
bout de temps parce que sam été pris par
une photographe et si tu aimes
mayer s'est passé à l'intérieur
alors la solution était simple la
circoncision de très belles personnes
qui peuvent le faire pour pas cher après
ça je suis passé un peu sur les télés
locales a bien sûr j'ai trouvé une
nouvelle perle ça s'appelle le salon de
brigitte alors c'est un peu comme studio
daniel mais avec brigitte
du coup c'est plus le même délire et la
brigitte nous attiser la prochaine
grosse soirée qu'elle organise alors
attention c'est la fête quand je vois ça
j'ai envie de poser un rtt pour elle et
à sa soirée
donc qu'est ce que tu vas faire bientôt
donc bientôt je serai je serai avec toi
pour un spectacle en fin fin septembre
et oui on va faire la fête
oui donc c'est la fête oui mais là ça
fait plaisir de voir
non mais c'est vrai l'enfant d'enora et
de girard pour les embrasse tous les
deux dit voilà et deuxième grosse
nouvelle que nous dit on va la revoir
votre deuxième grosse nouvelle que nous
a annoncé brigitte c'est la spéciale sur
les sosies qu'elle organise alors co
animée par jean ni hollande le sosie
officiel de françois hollande a
malheureusement pas jean milhau londres
son grenier j'ai fait une soirée avec
meet the way malheureusement absent de
l'otan à françois hollande que moi je
ressemble à thomas ngijol
alors d'abord je dois vous annoncer une
belle surprise
oui je serai sur scène pour présenter la
soirée
mais je serai pas seul je serai en duo
avec mon ami jean mi hollande qui est le
sosie officiel de monsieur françois
hollande et vous verrez il est vraiment
son sosie
on pourrait s'y méprendre
[Applaudissements]
le matelas je me disais mais je
ressemble à françois hollande
je suis désolé et brigitte jeu là qui
viendraient l'invité sur le côté de
vienne
brigitte michaud l'ado est il qu'à
vienne avec françois hollande mais il
ressemble à françois hollande mes frères
il ressemble pour ça jean michel maire
la blague sur l ouvrage de bonne
maîtresse aider quand on a d'autres
choses devaient pas bien sûr après ça je
suis allé dans la rue bah bien sûr comme
vous le savez à chaque fois j'aime bien
poser des questions gênantes au français
dans la rue malheureusement quand c'est
trop gênant et français n'aiment pas
répondu coup pour les appâter je leur
pose une question sur un petit sujets
qui les intéressent échange de quelques
petites situations malaise entre un
petit peu yui est-ce que vous pensez que
le bio est devenu accessible pas cela
vous dérange même répondre à ça parce
caméras n'ont pas de soucis comment vous
avez je suis avec yoann fans de
l'émission et marseillais contre le
reste du monde qui vient de purée pour
le départ de kevin hahn hon et moi je
vais pour le bio là non on va parler
vite fait de boubacar ys je me dis quand
on est à l'antenne ces bons est 3,2 à je
suis avec malicki ademe qui depuis trois
mois maintenant sont en couple je me dis
tu me dis quand c'est bon je reviens
vers toi mais roanne ça je suis avec
celui qu'on appelle merouane le jour
mais ça m'ira la nuit dans les bars à
chicha samira la nuit les choses ne
parlait buback à risque heureusement on
peut faire ça parce qu'à mon prénom
c'est brice enquête très bas 3 2 à je
suis avec brice brice qui a décidé de
nous expliquer pourquoi il a mis sa tête
dans le cul d'une marmotte
j'ai pas j'étais bourré je pense c'est
un actif et là moi je voudrais savoir si
vous pensez que le bio c'est accessible
ou pas c'est quoi votre révérence francs
soit très bien je suis avec françoise
françois ce qui est et ce tous de
sex-toys pour l'émission m6 boutique de
quoi de sextoys non c'est bon
[Applaudissements]